I uh I grew up in Glen Cove New York on
Long Island 1945.
I was born with glaucoma horrible eye
disease
when I was three years old they removed
my right eye because of glaucoma
and when I was seven years old
I lost my eyesight totally
now I'd like to talk about my family for
a little bit mama papa my father
Salvatore Brazil
left Calabria Italy in 1919 came to
America
moved to Glen Cove
settled in a little Italian neighborhood
called The Orchard
and soon after and I mean soon after
like it felt like the next day there was
an arranged marriage
so I'm thinking back I don't think in
1919 they did a lot of dating no I don't
think so
I think the Italians came over they said
hello I do and let's have a family and
don't worry about it
so my father was going to marry my
Mother Frances Godzilla
my father was 30 years old Francis
14.
when my mother was alive she told me
this story so many times about how her
mother
told her why she had to marry Salvatore
Brazil why
now my grandmother I have to imitate her
because she was hilarious my grandmother
was very animated she spoke broken
English
but well it really wasn't broken it was
more like
destroyed English yeah destroy and her
arms would wave and she's very animated
she'd come in the house and say a story
but now why do you do a storm in the Sun
that was Grandma
so Grandma told my mother
Ma
you know
himself because in Italy
a richer man whoa
he got a lot of money yeah you know what
he got it he got a chicken
he got a pork Pig
he pulled the milk from the cow like
this yeah he got a sheep a plantation
sheep he Rich a man he rich man
yeah in Italy he was Donald Trump in
America he was broke so they got married
had the reception at the Italian
American Club in the orchard
nice big party after the party Francis
the 14 year old bride leaves the
building
by herself
and walks two blocks back through the
orchard back to a mother's house
her mother opens the door and says Ah
what do you do here
Francis
well Mom I did what you said I I married
Salvatore now I'm home
you home
your Homer
homers
oh
thank you
and no
you know living here no more
just to know your house you got to go
with him and hear you for spinning
Francis didn't have a clue
no but
she went back to uh to her husband and
eventually she got it
how do I know there
because I'm the last of 16 kids oh yeah
she got it and got it
my poor mother she was like like an
Italian Pez dispense one after another
after another
and then
and then heartache
six of those 16 kids died not at Birth
but at two and three years old from
diseases back in those days
my mother was crushed
and what made it worse the last one born
me
with these horrible eye problems
I tell you I spent as a little boy so
much of my young life with my mother
she was miserable most of the time
I know it I felt it I was there
yeah
and then Mama started to drink
a lot
I never knew how Mama's drinking was
gonna
affect me in my life for years to come
not a clue
when I was a little boy I had had 12 eye
surgeries 12. the first one I was 11
months old
I want to describe
when I went in for an eye surgery what
what horror
waited for me every time I went in for a
new surgery
me and my mother back in those days had
we had this routine week after week
month after month year after year this
was the routine we'd get on a train in
Glen Cove go into the city into the eye
near Hospital the doctors would walk me
in a room
examine my eye and send this home
three weeks later four weeks later get
on the train in Glen Cove go into the
city into the eye near Hospital the
doctors walked me in a room examined my
eye
and send us all
six weeks later eight weeks later
get on a train go into the city into the
hospital
but this time
it was no eye examination when those
elevator doors would open and Mama
walked me in
I knew what was coming
Mama didn't want to tell me that I had
to stay for another eye surgery because
she knew I would scream and cry and
cause havoc
which I did I held on to her and begged
her for hours not to leave me I cried
she cried
it was awful
but she had to leave and after she left
I sat there
thinking about
what tomorrow is going to bring
yeah tomorrow
they'd wake me up early in the morning
give me an injection of something to
make me woozy before surgery I hated it
I mean hated it I tried to fight it I I
held on to the bed and shook my head
shook my body and Shook and Shook and
fought it and fought it
he did it
because I knew
what was coming yeah
I would hear a phone ring I would hear a
Spanish nurse say Vicente
o r
my heart would start pounding
they would wheel a gurney up to the side
of the bed and roll me over on the
ground and strapped me down nobody said
a word not one word
they would wheel me down these long
hallways making left turns and right
turns
I would hear people talking people
laughing my heart pounding out of my
chest
into the elevator up to the third floor
into the operating room
I know it was the operating room because
it felt like I don't know it felt like
there was a million hot lights
everywhere
and then that horrifying
awful
I mean disgusting
scary smell of that drug called ether
I hated it
because
it would make me sick for day if the day
of the day when I was in the hospital
I knew what was coming
they would lay me on the operating table
strap me down and before I could even
scream
they would slap this ether mask on my
face
I would start gagging choking couldn't
catch my breath it felt like I was gonna
die right there on the table
and and all I would hear was a sweet
nurse with a sweet voice say breathe it
in Vincent
breathe it in oh Vincent breathe it in
yeah breathe it in
[__] I had to breathe it in I had no
choice
and when I did
that drug dropped me into the most
horrifying nightmare of my life
a nightmare that stayed with me until I
was in my 40s
and this was a nightmare
I was in a fetal position
trapped in a metal tank I could move I
couldn't breathe and there were people
outside the tank banging on the tank
with a hammer screaming my name louder
and louder
Vincent Van Cent
I thought I lost my mind
I felt like I lost my mind
after surgery
I'd wake up they had restraints on my
arms so I couldn't touch my eyes
there was a ringing in my ears that was
deafening
to the point where I could barely hear
people talk
the room was spinning
spinning
and spinning
my life was spinning
I did say I knew it was coming right
yeah and every time I went in for
another eye surgery it came
it came
and it kept coming
so after a couple of weeks they would
Release Me From the hospital
now I was seven years old
I had partial sight in my left eye
I want to tell you about
the most horrifying moment of my life
and that's when
I lost my eyesight
every Sunday me mama papa
a couple of my brothers would go visit
one of my brothers who was who stationed
at Fort Dix New Jersey in the Army we'd
go there on a Sunday and have a picnic
and visit with him
I'm sitting at the table I got up from
the table because across the way I saw
my favorite [__] willows I loved them I
had them at home I used to touch them
and feel they were so soft
so I got up and I started to walk
towards the [__] with us
and I stopped turned around looked at
the family at the table okay
kept walking
and it started to get foggier in fog
here I didn't panic because I was used
to it
turned around look at the family
kept walking
and he got foggier
I turned around look at the family
at the [__] willows
back to the family
and then my world went black
in a flesh
I screamed
I felt the Earth shaking when I screamed
I'd hear my scream in Texas
it felt like the whole
Crown opened up and swallowed me it was
awful
it was awful
now
I was blind totally couldn't see
anything black
I I didn't think at that time that my
world could get worse that anything
could be worse than this
but it happened
you see
my blindness I couldn't walk around the
house
to where I used to I didn't know where I
was in my own house I was walking into
walls I was walking into tables I'm
walking into chairs and
my mother
would would
sit me down in a chair or sit me down on
a on a couch to keep me in one spot
when I need to go to the bathroom she
had to walk me to the bathroom
I didn't know what anything was anymore
no
in those days I slept with two of my
brothers there were three in a bed house
was filled with kids they stacked us
like chairs
and there were those nights when I would
wake up screaming and yelling and crying
from these horrible nightmares that I
had
my brothers thought I was nuts they
thought I was crazy he said what's the
matter with you go back to you you're
waking up everybody shut up go back to
somebody who nuts are you crazy
yeah they thought I was crazy
I thought I was crazy
and then there were those nights when I
would be woken up in the middle of the
night where everybody in this house was
screaming the walls were shaking the
house felt like it was going to collapse
and it was mama and papa again in the
middle of the night
fighting punching each other screaming
crying the house
it's like a looney pin I didn't know
where to run I didn't know where to hide
I was trembling
how the [__] do I get out of here
how do I leave
I hated my life
I hated this blind thing that was
destroying my life
I want to go anywhere I would go
anywhere with anybody I want a different
house different family I want I want it
out somewhere somewhere anyway
I sat there one day and I never forget
this like I said I got it all I need is
a car if I had a car I'd get in the car
drive away never ever come back
a car
but they didn't teach blind kids
at eight years old I had to drive in
those days
1953 no they weren't teaching it
I was screwed I had nowhere to go
it was that blind thing
yeah
mama
found a way to keep me in one spot
put me in the front yard and I spent
most of the day sitting there listening
to the sounds of the neighborhood
and Mama inside the house crying way too
much to drink again
crying screaming asking God why me
why me
I'd sit there and say why you
why me what do you mean I'm waiting for
anybody somebody to come and get me and
get me the hell out of here why you
why me
I would go with anybody
I mean it I sat there and said I
kidnapped me I wish there was a kidnap
there's got to be
a kidnapper somewhere
who had this idea let me go kidnap her
and they wrote blanket I'm here cause
waiting for you come get me
swear I used to beg for that
but uh little did I know that some help
was coming there was a barber who had a
shop across the street from me his name
was Sal
he used to watch me every day sit in my
yard I would cry
listening to Mama scream from the house
Sal walked over to me one day and took
my hand and took me back to a shop
across the street
and he said to me Vincent
sound you're hearing they have music
you have to feel it with your heart it's
music you need that music more than you
need your eyesight
thought it was that it was [__] much
kidding me
then he took out his guitar and started
singing to me had a beautiful voice
listen to the music he's saying
find your song Within
listen to the music find your voice
within
he did this I don't know two three times
a week and then he would teach me how to
sing a song and if this went on for I
don't know for months
that barber threw me a lifeline
gave me something I desperately needed
in my life at that time
something to believe in something to
hold on to
a dream to chase through my life
something to have
music
yeah I wanted to be a star I love
singing I could sing
I wanted to be famous I wanted to be a
star and I was going to do it I could do
it I could do it I know it yes
but before the star could become a star
I still was City
in the front yard every day listening to
the sounds of the neighborhood and then
in those days
kids
would would fill the streets and play
the games of the day you know Hopscotch
jump rope baseball
I would sit there and cry sometimes
because I couldn't play with it they
were right there and I couldn't pull it
I felt like I was in prison
I wanted to get up and scream as they
get the [__] out of here leave me alone
but I couldn't
and then one day I heard all these kids
all of a sudden scream um
there's a monster run run there's a
monster I said what kind of monster
where's the monster what monster
I was approached by a young boy
he introduced himself to me his name was
Walter
this was Walter's first day in the ocean
as a foster child
Walter was born
with a horribly horribly disfigured
phase
I didn't know that
he came to me and said why aren't you
afraid
I said afraid of what
a faith so I can't see your face I'm
blind
you're blind I said yeah
he says well don't you want to play
don't you want to play baseball don't
you want to well you're just going to
sit there and say how am I going to do
that I I can't see
he says
I want to be my friend
I'll teach you I'll teach you how to
play baseball I have a bicycle we could
ride around laugh have some fun
you want to be my friend
I says your friend
I didn't have any friends I needed a
friend I said yes I'll be your friend
let's be friends
well let me tell you what this kid did
he took me behind the school it was a
block up from my house
teach me baseball he had a baseball bat
he cut the thin handle off the baseball
bat put it in my hand taught me how to
hit the ball he would catch the ball
bounce the ball back to me and scream
Vinnie listen for the bounce get the
ball hit it back to me
I would listen get it boom
I was playing baseball
I never did this even when I had partial
sight I never did I never thought this
was going to happen to me
it was unbelievable I was playing
baseball then Walter took me behind the
orchard there was a brook
he took me down
take our shoes and socks off and Wade
through the water walk through the brook
this was unbelievable I never did these
things
then we said
under a train trestle and felt that the
rumble of the train when it would go
past overhead it was
then he would catch frogs put him in my
hand let me touch them he would describe
them to me
but a new life
and then and then one day he said let's
build a hut
he had wood he had Nails he had hammers
he gives me a hammer gives me a nail
tells me to nail the Hat uh uh hammer
the nail I go to hammer the nail of
course I hit my hand I said like I'm
doing this [__]
he says I'll stop you stupid blind guy
I said there's some pie face don't tell
me
about
hitting my hand with the with a hand
we loved each other
we love each other
oh yeah
I'll tell you something
I met Walt when I was 11 years old I was
desperate he opened up my life
I felt like I was in prison he unlocked
that prison for me and I unlocked his
prison because people would stare at him
people would Point people with a laugh
people would turn away we had each other
that wasn't an accident
unbeknownst to me in those days my
blindness allowed me to get to know one
of God's most beautiful Creations get to
know and love
my buddy my friend
my soul mate
my angel
Walter
you see I didn't know Jesus in those
days
but he certainly knew me
oh yeah
he knew me
so now I met him when I was 11. now I'm
14 years old I'm a singer taught myself
I'm a singer and I'm a drummer I love
the drums taught myself how to play
I had my first rock and roll group I put
together I was growing up I was changing
I even though I had so much anger in me
all the time and fear
I still had this hope and this drive to
be a star I was going to be famous
and I even started to poke fun at this
thing that I hated my blindness
I named my first group Vinnie and the
Venetian blinds people thought I was
crazy
I said I love it
starting to grow up I'd had the names
for the group too you know the groupers
and that kind of thing so that
so now I'm 15 years old in in high
school and I want to talk about briefly
the the
[Music]
um Blind Association in those days that
I hated
the association for the Blind and I hate
it and I I mean hated afraid two quick
stories
the high school
I went to the system wanted to bring in
a guy with a cane to teach me how to
walk
I said I know how to walk I don't need a
cane my legs are fine I'm they said no
no no this is to help blind people
you know with the independence
I says I'm independent are you kidding
I'm playing drums I'm singing I'm
chasing girls I'm fine I'm independent
no problem
they bring the guy down
guy takes me outside on the sidewalk
puts my hand in the prop the place on
the uh
and then we start walking down the
sidewalk
tick tock tick tock tick tock
after about a tent Tick Tock I threw
it down on the ground
I says I'm done this is not happening I
feel like a blind alarm clock ain't
happening
[__] not happening it's not for me I
gave the system a tough time I was angry
and I was a tough kid
I know what I wanted
oh yeah
then they did one more
the association for the blind
they they sent me with 40 blind kids and
some teachers to Statue of Liberty
can you imagine 40 blind kids walking up
the winding staircase of the Statue of
Liberty some were chipping some were
falling uh some other kids were stepping
on kids that were tripping and falling
it was a mess and then all of a sudden
this Caravan stops
and the teacher makes an announcement
children were in the knee
I said we're in the nick who's knee
what knee
and why are we in the knee there's no
need here there's steps this is baloney
and all the blind kids around me are
saying oh we're in the knee oh this is
wonderful wow we're in the I said but
what do you this is [__] dude this
is the steps that go what's the matter
with you guys
hmm
I couldn't understand it
so we tripped back down the steps and
went to lunch
I'm sitting at the table with all these
blind kids and some teachers and I'm
talking to this blind kid William I said
William where are you from
William looks up to the ceiling and says
I'm from Westbury
I look at him I look at the seal and he
says
wait let me ask you a question is
somebody pissing on your head look at me
they never looked at me all of these
blankets their heads would go this way
when they talk that way never looked at
me I didn't understand made me feel
shitty made me feel blind
I don't want it that system was not for
me I knew what I wanted out of life and
I was going after it oh yeah
now
my blindness
you know I didn't realize this at the
time but my blindness helped me
deal with so many uh
tough tough situations helped me to deal
with so many tough situations
back in the 50s I I grew
I grew up in a place that um oh I grew
up at a time where Prejudice and racism
was just about an acceptable part of
everyday life oh yeah the n-word would
just fly off the
people's tongues even though I was blind
I was prejudiced yeah
I hated like a lot of people did
I knew who to hate
but I didn't know why
now I'm 15 years old in high school
beginning of a new school year they had
to find somebody to walk me from class
to class you know get me around
so they picked this kid Roy and me and
Roy became friends great kid funny kid I
really really liked him
and then
one day some kids came over to me and
said what are you doing hanging out with
royal don't you know he's black
I didn't know Roy was black I was
horrified
I was like mortified Roy's black
but I said something
back in those days that I thought I
would never say
it's too late to hate him
he's my friend
oh yeah I loved Roy we were buddies we
would go to the bathroom I would raise
my hand and ask the teachers guys
we went to the bathroom not to go to the
bathroom to smoke in those days
so were you in the bathroom smoking one
day
young black kid comes into the bathroom
tries to hustle me for money before I
could even open my mouth to Roy beat the
[__] out of this kid beat him to a pump
a black boy beating one of his own kind
to protect the white kid
in 1959
I wish the world could have seen that
yeah
and I look back
my blindness because if I had eyesight
no way in the world in those days I
would have ever allowed myself to make
friends with joy no way
it's just the way it was really was
so now I'm 19 years old
we had a manager we were going on the
road we're going to do a string of
colleges yeah I was thrilled now I'm
going to become a star I'm going after
it it's here
all right
but before I could leave
mama has something she had to tell me
she said
Sal the barber died
I says I
oh terrible oh that guy who helped me
with my music
helped me to sing wow
oh I felt terrible
she said he left him money and then she
starts crying my mother
I said left me what what's going on
you said Vincent
true you are
the Barber's son
I'm telling you I felt like somebody
shot me
I started the stamina stutter
i i i i i i what do you mean what does
this mean what are you saying I don't
understand what does this mean I it's
like I lost the ability to to understand
the English language what are you saying
what
I was numb I went in the other room
slammed the door set down to try to get
my world to stop spinning
spinning
I was on a roller coaster was awful
and then
I understood
those words mama told me
I'm telling you I had more anger in me
than any 50 people
I wanted to go outside and I wanted to
hit her and I wanted to hit her
it was
awful
for the next
25 or 30 years
I ran through life
screaming as loud as I could running as
fast as I could
carrying every
insane crazy emotion humanly possible
oh yeah I played all over I went to
Europe many times I
wanted to be a star
yeah
I wanted to be a star
sex drugs rock and roll that was my life
and nobody was going to take it from me
that was my life and I was good I was a
I was a a good Entertainer I love people
I love breaking balls and having a great
time I had a great sense of humor uh
it was like
chicks love me not because of my looks
because of the attitude
poking fun at my blindness and I had a
really good Soulful voice Man Ray
Charles was my hero yeah
it was good it was working it was
happening for me
back in those days I was crazy I mean I
got locked up twice I was a I was a big
kid in those days I I used to lift
weights I'd go in a bar after a gig or
something it'd be a little too drunk or
start a fight started I punched the cop
once they locked me up twice
pain in the ass blanket
out of control
oh yeah as a matter of fact in those
days
I got married not once twice three times
somebody told me a long time ago that
blind guys don't pay alimony
so I got married
he kept getting married
but I yeah gotta tell you that blind
guys do pay alimony oh yeah
so I went all in my life I was playing
locally in Glen coven years later
and I always wanted to open up a
recording studio now I had the money and
I did in Glen Cove I had a little
apartment above the studio where I
stayed
this was what I wanted music all day
long and party at night
I was the captain of my own ship man
but when that ship
started to sink
there was nothing
nothing I could do about it
I was walking across the studio floor
one day there turn on the stereo to
listen to music
and all of a sudden there was this
Christian station
music I said
what the hell is that
and I'm telling you almost immediately
almost immediate I fell to the floor I
had no idea what the hell just happened
what this was
I tried to get up I couldn't get up I
didn't know if I was having a seizure a
heart attack I didn't know what was
going on I had I tried to get up three
four times
now I'm panicking scared to death I
don't know what this is I'm alone in the
studio I felt like I was going to die on
the floor in my studio
didn't know what was happening to me
the only thing I could do was crawl I
crawled to the phone and called my
musical partner and best friend Elisa
sunshine
she was a singer keyboard player she
came running over Elisa sat down on the
floor of the studio
I was lying on the floor of the studio
with my head in her lap
we had no idea what this was
but we knew one thing whatever it was it
was serious
and then all of a sudden me Vinnie
started to cry
like a baby
and these words came out of my mouth
that I had no control over
I'm dying I'm smothering there's no love
where's the love I never gave it I never
had it I never got it I need to touch it
where is the love I need to have it I
need to touch it where is it
where is love I don't have it
don't have
Lisa thought I was out of my mind I
thought I was nuts
what am I saying I had no control me
where's the love I gotta have what the
hell's the matter with me what is this
it was insane
this went off for a bit then it subsided
and
Lisa wanted to take me to the hospital I
said no no I'm okay I'm all right
she finally left
with some weird crazy things started
happening on top of that
I would be alone in the studio sitting
down
and all of a sudden my body would be
enveloped by this feeling that I was
floating
Flo and I'm talking about like I wasn't
in my body anymore or the studio
I said is this
and I got to tell you about the feeling
I had that this thing gave me
tremendous fear
it was weird and crazy
but peaceful
it was so strange
then it would disappear
and this would happen only when I was
alone not when there was a bunch of
people around or if I was playing a gig
no
I didn't know what this was it would
happen
and then it would disappear
I'll tell you the truth I said to myself
one day it's one of two things it's
either God
or I'm losing my [__] mind
and I thought I was losing my mind
I couldn't control it couldn't stop it
but I had to get back to my life music
was my life that's where I was making
money and that's where the party was
that my my life was music
so this happened to me in 1984 1985 in
my studio
and these feelings kept happening
I want to take us to the year 2000.
I went to bed one night
and had a dream of Walter
and Roy
and I woke up and I sat there and I and
I said
for the first time in my life
I actually
felt that my blindness was a gift
I never thought that way before always
thought it was a penny yes I hated it
because if I didn't have my blindness
if I had eyesight I would have never
made friends with Roy never
the color of the skin no
if I had eyesight
I would have been just like the other
kids would would Walter pointed at him
and laughed at him
my blindness was a gift
and for the first time I realized it I
went to my partner Elisa and I told her
about my dream I said she said listen to
me Vinnie I got an idea you have an
incredible that's an incredible story
you let's write some songs about Walter
and Roy
and put a program together and let's go
into schools and
share this with these kids they would
love it
so that's what we did we went into high
schools we we went at the colleges and
different organizations the reaction we
got I got was incredible
and for the first time in my life I felt
good
I don't mean good good like chasing
chicks and having a party no no I meant
a good I never felt before
clean good
God had his arms around me and I knew it
oh I know it this wasn't the old Vinny
thinking this way feeling this way no
it was incredible
and I'm going to tell you that
my life I felt was like climbing trying
to climb Mount Everest with mudslides
and hurricanes and and I was trying and
trying I
this next event in my life
brought me
to the top of Mount Everest yeah
I was playing with my band and a friend
of mine used to come down and see me
play every night my name was Marianne
klutz
Marianne was the manager of a
school for special need kids she said
Vinnie you gotta work for us you got to
work these kids would love you with your
attitude your personality your singing
you please your energy you gotta
I was a little taken back by that so I
said let me observe went to school
there was a guy sitting there with a
guitar playing the guitar the kids want
to get up and touch the guitar guys no
no no stay in your seats don't move you
just listen to me play and it's and I'm
sitting here looking at this I'm saying
it's [__]
was the interaction
kids need interaction
so I took the job
I walked in to observe a room my first
day on a job
there were eight little ten-year-old
kids in wheelchairs
and they had this syndrome I don't know
what the name of the syndrome is but
their brains stopped growing at the age
of three years old
and their bodies grew kept growing
and there was a therapist there with one
of the kids with a Shaker and she said
to the kid
okay put the Shaker in your hand and
shake the shaker
kid goes into it so the woman put the
Shaker in the kid's hand and the woman
shook the kids hair I know what she was
doing
and then she writes in a book child
shakes the child says this is [__]
crazy what are you kidding me
so the first day I went in that room
with this little girls
I walked in and then I started dancing
and jumping you want to sing You Want To
Dance come on let's go and the kids all
of a sudden waving their hands and
laughing and making noise and laughing
and screaming and and I'm jumping around
and I'm going from Kid to Kid yeah yeah
don't look teacher was mortified
I said to the teacher this is called fun
um
and then I met
a little girl named Gracie 15 years old
she was blind
a lot of mental serious mental problems
and violence she had
streaks of violence
I got to know her make her laugh sing
did my routine jump and laughed and come
on let's sing a clap our hands she loved
me
to the point where
I was the only one pretty much that they
could handle her they made me her
one-on-one
and the school was going to have this uh
talent show so I said to Gracie Gracie
you're going to sing in the talent show
you're going to sing a multi a Motown
song Yes I want to you gotta learn I'm
going to teach you and Gracie you know
okay all right all right okay great
two months I work with this kid
data talent show
I went on stage with her
she sang A Motown song the place went
nuts
and all these professionals after
came to myself how the hell are you do
that how how are you doing this so I
I said
I have no degree
it's my only answer I have no degree I
think people with too many degrees lose
touch with real life that was my theory
whether I was right or wrong I have no
idea I didn't care
didn't matter
now
I thought about I worked there for 10
years by the way 10 years in that school
but all these beautiful kids someone
they loved me they get off the bus in
the morning and they'd send me to come
running up to me let's dance let's sing
and hugging and kissing me and oh it's
amazing and then I thought of that night
at the studio that day the studio when I
was crying for love
where is the love
it was there
the love that I cried for years before
I was getting every day from those kids
love that I needed love that I never had
love
that I wanted
they gave me
wow
and then of course there was the goofy
stupid not even where I would flirt with
all the women in the school
and the women a couple of the women in
the office said to me one day Vinnie
stay away from our new nurse her name is
Marianne leave her alone I said no
problem
I went from the office straight to the
nurses office and I introduced myself to
the nurse by saying uh no see pull
take my pulse please
she laughed and said I was warned about
you
well me and Mary and the nurse flirted
for a couple of months in school back
and forth
we fell in love
we were together 16 years we've been
together
16 years
and during those 16 years I asked her to
marry me a bunch of times and she would
say I don't know we'll see uh
she said you've got a bad reputation
she said oh we have to wait I said no
I'm good after 16 years I was a good boy
I was a good boy
I was changing
God had his arms around me and she knew
it
so we got married September 24th my
birthday
the year 2022
and my 77th birthday we got married
I have to tell you
that Jesus
walked me through hell in this life
and I didn't know it standing by my side
I didn't know it keeping me from
destroying myself because the truth of
the matter is if
I shouldn't be here
the things that I'd done in my life I
should not be here
I'm here
I thought I was going to be here to be a
star and a zillionaire and a no
I'm here
to share my story with as many people as
possible Lisa my partner and I have put
together
a program
a testimony with music an hour and a
half see I've given you bits and pieces
of my life there's a lot more oh yeah
put together an hour and a half program
with music that was given to me over the
years
through dreams
oh yeah
pretty incredible
so now we we have shared this in
churches organizations
and I'm telling you that the reception
is incredible it's beautiful
beautiful so I'm asking you all whoever
sees this
please we have a website we just put up
go to my website
it's called the gift ofblindness.com
the gift of blindness.com please help me
to share this story with as many people
as possible
it is so important I need that
I need it because that's why I'm here
very great story
thank you so much okay man